and turning to an event tonight a vigil
is being held for 24 year old destiny
jackson her body was found in a desert
area south of las vegas a day after she
was reported missing friends and family
have gathered in an intimate ceremony to
honor her tonight madison kimbrough is
there and she joins us live now with
more madison
the vigil just started and like you
mentioned friends and family are all
gathered you can see them right behind
me
here for quite some time remembering
jackson as the charming young woman she
was to give you a little back story an
instagram post showed jackson was out a
mutual friend said jackson was supposed
to pick up her boyfriend but never
showed up on sunday jackson's mother
said she got a call from the coroner
saying that jackson's body was found by
a hiker in a desert area near sloan
south of las vegas jackson's aunt maria
says this whole ordeal has their family
in disbelief and hopes that today's
ceremony will bring them some peace
if her soul's still here we're here to
take her home
and
we came
to get closer some closure to us
of
where she was dumb
and so that we can
move on and move on to the next chapter
again the vigil just started at six and
we plan on talking to more family
members and friends as you can see
people are gathered and the vigil
ceremony is just underway so keep it
here on 8 news now we plan on giving you
continuing coverage coming up at 11
tonight on this vigil reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now